Hello, hello, oh my god, I am so, oh my gosh, I hear myself, why do I hear myself?
Oh, it's because I have another tab open.
I have another stream open.
Okay, but yeah, I'm super nervous.
I have never talked to Big Bird before, but yes, there's the meeting of birds.
I just need Angry Bird now, and then the bird trifecta is complete.
But yes, today I am getting coached by the Big Bird.
and what's funny um when i was like um uh i was like asking uh because like you know my manager made my waiting room for me and then my manager was like what's big bird social and then i was just like just google it and he was and then he just sent me a picture of big bird from sesame street he's like i don't think this is the one you're collabing with right i was
is the Sesame Street Big Bird?
Because I don't know which Big Bird you're talking about.
And I was like, no, no, Big Bird.
And then look up Big Bird, FGC.
Yeah, we don't know that for sure.
That could be him in the Big Bird suit.
You're right.
Have we ever seen Big Bird from Sesame Street?
And Big Bird, the Street Fighter player in the same room?
Hmm.
um um but yeah i am so nervous this will be my very first time um talking to them i you know i shot my shot were mutuals from the last stage i'm slammed because i think you watched me when i played gif i'm sorry that i'm not a gif player anymore i i have cemented i know like yesterday i was like i don't know i don't know which one to pick do i pick zane gif or do i pick today today i'm
all i did was just go headbutt headbutt headbutt headbutt and then i got a nine game win streak i've never had that with zangif i swear to god when i was playing zangif it was i i had to play a fucking mind game to like get close to a person to get a grapple in i have to be like all right how How do I get close to you so I can grab you?
But there as the Honda, all I do was just like, headbutt.
I absolutely, I don't believe, I posted it on Twitter.
I legitimately, all I did was just, I just abused this.
Sometimes I'd swap it up a little bit by using the DUI move.
That's my mix up.
If headbutt don't work, I use my DUI.
Wait, okay.
For those who don't, but me, bam!
Look at that.
And then I went against a jury that figured out my next move.
It's like, because they're like, there's no way she's going to use the headbutt again.
And they always think that.
I don't know why.
They never, they're like, there's no way she's going to use the headbutt again.
But then I do.
will say i got the silver five and then for some reason those players figured out that only know like two mooms essentially i don't know how they figured it out but i've i've been like hard stuck silver five for an hour but yet i got the nine game win streak after an hour of playing stuck in silver five after these players you're so smart i don't know how they figured it out but they figured it out that i can only do like one to two moves i don't know though i don't know how they figured that out it's so it's a mystery like the gap between iqs the gap between iqs of silver four to silver five is actually insane um i like cruise through from silver one to silver four just doing headbutt and then it felt like silver five players are like 50 IQ points above silver four uh it's like they're an ai that daft to me i know i swear to god they must be ai they aren't real they must be they must be smurfing how dare they know how to block um yeah anyway so uh so we're gonna stick with i'm sorry i
know for all the the the dogeef uh the dogeef fans i'm so sorry for my loyal fans that it has to come this way but you know how i'm saying geef i literally gave up on rink at apparently nephew was like yeah you ended on silver four and then you fucking gave up because it was so tilting and i was like that sounds like me uh but i struggled so hard silver like so like to get to silver for it but then i literally in honda i was it was like a walk on the park i felt like i was literally just like scrolling around the park the sun is out and i'm so happy i was like like i grinded more on zangief in rank than i ever did on honda like my peak I peed like I have my highest rank is on Honda and I have less than five hours on Honda that's the saddest part it's actually that's the saddest part five hours of Honda and I have a higher rank than my Zankeep which I struggled so much on it was fun though I will say that uh yeah it was so Yeah,
Honda was like the perfect cheese for me.
But I specifically came for Geek Volume 2.
I'm sorry.
This is Street Fighter's fault.
Buff Zang Geek.
And I'll come back as Geek, guys.
Hashtag Buff him.
And so DeHonda's head game is crazy.
What if you add playing from the right side?
Okay, no, that's too much.
We do not play on the right side.
If I'm on the right side, I'm gonna jump.
I'm gonna find my way to go go back to the
Yeah, we will riot if you want me back on The second tournament above Zangief.
That's the only way I'll come back
Zangief is like 30 tiers above e Honda what is in this one top tiers.
What are you?
Yeah, yes, but I am in the baby level okay like i am in the baby elo and the thing is the players in baby elo do not know what the fuck to do with the headbutt while in zhangif the way to for me to be able to use my cheesy move of grappling is i have to slowly get to them and i have to close the gap between me and the other player on zhangif but the thing with honda is i have one move that can I don't have to walk over.
I don't have to slowly walk over at Zangief.
I could literally use one move to close the gap between me and the opponent on Honda.
So, like, that's like...
Walking is so hard.
You don't understand.
Walking is so hard in baby level.
So, we're gonna stick with Honda.
If Zangief if ever gets buffed again um i'll come and i get invited to a tournament i'll come back you hear that capcom it's for my loyal fans i'll do it um wink wink uh but yes i also know exactly who i'm fighting on fighting with um so there is one player that i'm a bit scared of because like she did previous say jam slams already and see I think she did like two streets so someone dropped out yeah someone dropped out um um like a beginner dropped out and so I am worried about the person that was replacing her because she did two say jam slams before I did one for street fighter she did two but yet she's placed in baby level so that's like what I well yeah but it's been a year I didn't touch the game for a year and I think she had more recent experience than me like but yet she is also in the baby baby tier so um so that's what i'm worried about because she's like in baby tier um but yet she has more experience than me um but then the other two are also like babies as well like the
other two i'm not as scared i'm just scared of the other one that might not be as baby as the other two yeah um so that's what i'm worried about she plays apparently she plays a key as well so uh so she has more experience than all of us there down there so well my main goal is to win one game and like i was i was telling nephew i was like i'm so scared about like because i lost my win streak to a jury and um to a jury and then um i was like i'm so scared because one of the players are playing jury apparently and then he was like you're fine she's eye and rank and i was like yeah but i'm silver i was like i don't know it's like what if she gets to silver and then he nephew was like don't worry you'll be diving back then and he has such high x i have no idea why the fuck you thinks I am smart enough to get there but I was like I don't know why he thinks that he has that much confidence in me I'm I don't know how why he thinks that he's a bit too confident in me
but yeah anyway I'm gonna call it big bird now I am I am super nervous ha ha ha ha my first time so I hope everything will be okay oh yeah as long as everyone believes in one game that's all I need to know apparently okay so the people I'm fighting I'm fighting Aki Ryu and jury and then I've got I'm like wait aren't all those characters sort of countering me like what the fuck I'm like wait that's not fair it's not fair what do you want they all play all these characters that are supposed what the fuck why they all counter me like that's not fair i pick this is why i should pick my character last this is like they all throw at me like no that's even worse what are you talking about back to keep what a fuck that is the major keep calendar what the fuck are you talking the biggest issue is the fact that i have someone and that's literally one of the biggest counters to keep so like so it's basically like okay even if i played the same keep it'd be like fuck you i guess also funny story
um after the capcon stream um after the capcon stream the one from yesterday uh um uh the production team was but like I think they're talking about me um please make sure you don't swear during the when you are on the broadcast when you're on the Capcom main channel please refrain from cursing and then and like after the stream was done and I was like I'm sorry I was like I think I think they were talking about me and I was like I'm so sorry I'm I was like I play FPS game so it comes to me of like the person that tweeted out they're like since joki's debut she has cursed like 60 000 times and i linked that tweet just to be like i'm so sorry like it's i'm it's a problem but i can censor myself for a sponsor i was like don't worry though i was just wasn't aware and i can censor myself on stream when i have to um obviously i lied but like they don't have to know that If you're watching,
if Capcom's on, I can censor myself.
I was just making a joke.
Don't worry.
Please do not, do not blacklist me.
Okay, all right, all right.
Um, okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna call.
Wow, I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Hello!
Hello, hello.
How are you?
Good chat.
This is big bird
Yeah, I'm so nervous.
I'm so nervous.
I'm because I should be doing nervous.
Okay, because like I found out the person Yeah, because like I'm in baby tier, but then the person that like Someone dropped out and then they replace someone that's not baby and like all three characters apparently counter me because they all throw fucking fireballs so so i'm like what do i do when he told me your car you the characters you are facing are you i can don't uh are you i can the jury i was like are you sure you want to play haunted what else did i do I already practiced on the we have one and a half days left bird like I don't know if I can fit a third character in my head it's okay um one of them I think I think it's gonna work I think it's gonna you gotta believe so the real okay I would normally be scared of the real character the most because like fuck that fuck the flowchart um uh but but I think they're weak the player is on Ryo because like I watch I was scouting you know I watched his stream and he was doing a practice stream today and he still hasn't finished
placements so I think I can beat and he was and he ended the stream fourth game placement so I think it's possible I can win it's I think I think I think it's very doable yeah we don't necessarily really doesn't counter honda especially at like you know beginner level yeah uh but he is gonna counter you if you only use you know headbutt yeah but like how would he know he'll think i use another move really who would use headbutt like 50 times in a row i think you should also use the the butt slam okay it's going to help you a lot there is a problem with that i'm i i might not be very consistent with the butt slam i'm i might be struggling with that one but but i know open up training wood okay okay okay it's it's look i'm i'm trying my best chat i i've got my nine game win streak without doing butt slam like well did you face any reuse did i face any what oh yeah i did i face any Yeah,
I faced the Rios.
They kicked my ass, but that's okay.
Because I beat one of them.
I remember beating one Rio.
And then I won in Dungeon.
You won in Dungeon, but you know you can't win in tournaments, right?
Yeah, but like that's not, that doesn't matter.
I think it matters a little bit.
No, they're not.
They won't adapt to me.
I believe they will never adapt.
to me because like if you believe that then yeah yeah yeah it's fine they there's no way they can adapt to me all right also uh sound guy brought big bird up a little bit let me know if he's um if you guys can hear him now all right so basically what i do is i do this and then if i feel a little spicy i do this and then if they get close i just grab him and those are just three and then my fourth move is this so like apparently nephew says i'm like a pokemon so if i try to learn a fifth move i have to forget i have to forget one you have to forget one of them yeah we have to replace the other one so i i tried okay like yes i can do it in training but like in theory i can do it but i think i think this move is really good because it it will go through the fireball like if someone is spamming a duken you can do that goes through it and then you get a like a small combo out of it there's a cop what combo so if you put the dummy oh wait let me show you uh let me show my okay yeah okay yeah
yeah you guys can't see the screen it's only for me only i get to see this so if someone
don't worry i'll try and replicate it chat on my own screen so it's not it's not going to be easy but yeah okay
what what oh oh yeah oh my god the little bounce the little bounce that you can combo but i'm not sure what if the combo is worth it for you but as long as you just get past the fireballs i think that's yeah yeah well how i do it is i just use this but then it does get my it does oh we're not that one but you know this to get past the fireball this is good but you also have the the level two super that goes through fireball as well oh wait how do i how How do I do that?
No, you just hold back and then you press your special button.
This one.
Yes, this one.
Oh!
This one goes through the fireball.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I got it.
I'll just use this.
Okay.
And then when you get close, then when you get close, you also have something else that you can do that you can just spam, which is, you know, which is perfect for you.
It shows your medium button.
Oh.
You're playing, yeah, this one.
This one, the good thing about it is it's plus and you can basically just spam this up close.
Wait, so I could just keep doing this?
Yeah, but like go back a bit.
Walk back a bit.
Yes, from this range.
This range.
Oh my god!
My arms are so long!
It's so good.
Oh my god!
Even like top players actually hate this button.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, this is my new.
It's headbutt, headbutt, and this.
you can do this into uh the 100 hand slap 100 hand slap wait how do i oh it's the one with a lot of hands yeah so you can do the medium into that oh like yeah basically but like that yes oh my god my new spammable move they'll never expect this move so the hand the hundred hand slap is uh is minus so It's not your turn obviously after that.
Wait, what does minus mean?
Oh, sorry.
I'm being too complicated here.
So basically it's not your turn anymore.
It's basically not your turn anymore.
They block it.
It's like...
So you need to...
Yeah, you need to be careful what button you press after that.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
But this one, the media punch is like you...
It's your turn afterwards, even on block.
Even if they block it.
Okay.
So maybe it's not worth it to cancel something.
times you know just keep doing the the media punch oh so just keep doing this yes this is good for spam okay uh until they show you that they can you know deal with it then you might you're gonna have to change it up a bit okay so when you get when you get them knocked down with when you get like knock someone down with the headbutt or whatever then you have the medium punch you have this this throw that you can use yeah uh you have your drive impact the one that you know the And then you have your regular throw.
Yes, this.
This one is good because it's safe.
Like, they can't punish you if they jump over you.
And if they jump over you, you can use your headbutts.
Oh, wait, but then like, I missed though.
What do you mean?
So like, so when they jump over me, like, they just, the headbutt doesn't hit.
So there's this thing in this game called autocorrect.
If they jump over you and you still do the moves, sometimes the move, the Honda goes to the other side.
So it auto-corrects for you where he's going.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
But it's not necessarily they jump to the other side.
Sometimes they just jump in their place, you know, to avoid the command throw.
Yeah, yeah.
So they start jumping, I should just continue headbutton.
You can just continue medium punching, or you can just do regular throw.
So they don't punish your...
Because if you do the other throw...
This one?
No, the other throw?
Yes.
No, no, not this one.
The other one.
Oh, not this one.
Oh, this one.
Yes, if they jump over this, they can punish you.
Oh, okay, so I should just do that.
Yes.
Like, switch it up between the two.
Yeah, when you get close.
Basically, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
combo the other so like for example the media punch hits do the media punch you can do you can do crowd jab afterwards uh you're playing controller right yeah i'm on the i'm on the uh the razor one but it has the playstation controller icons uh is that a leverless or no regular leverless yeah oh leverless so you're basically your first button what uh uh square triangle x square triangle x oh okay we don't we don't we don't say square triangle x square this is square yes yes so if you do the triangle button yeah no just do that triangle yeah that's your triangle that's your triangle that's a level square triangle uh x oh okay
so if you do the X you can do down square afterward this close yet close oh it combos oh my god he's pushing me away yeah well obviously it's gonna push you away so you can't do it infinitely it's not fair well if it's if you can do it infinitely it doesn't push you away we should give Honda infinite infinite slaps so I'll give you a little combo so Let me share my screen to make it easier.
Okay, so...
Wait, maybe we should go in a custom room.
No, it's gonna be laggy.
It's gonna be very laggy.
Okay, do you see my screen?
Yeah, I see a chat.
Okay, so basically...
What the fuck?
That's...
What did you do?
This?
It's just what I told you.
Oh, it's like this?
Yeah.
Oh my god, guys, I'm doing a combo!
Oh my god, I'm not doing a combo.
Okay, slow down a bit.
Don't get too excited.
I got too excited, guys.
Like that?
Yeah, but yes, this one, exactly.
So even, so let me tell you on the secret.
Even on hit or on block, you can just do this because it's your turn either way.
Wow.
Okay.
But you have to get close.
Oh.
What?
But how do I keep doing it if I miss?
Never mind.
Yeah, you're missing it.
No, it's okay.
It's something you're gonna get used to.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, but do I have to move closer after?
Like, do I have to move up?
Yeah, you have to move up.
Oh, okay.
100 hand slap it's gonna push you away and then after you do the 100 hand slap yeah if you're actually close wait
how's okay wait oh no uh basically just keep doing this as well oh so i could just this is very good okay yeah this is very good and then you can if you feel like it you can cancel into you know headbutt afterwards oh and then just do that yeah basically after after you uh your x button oh after my oh no i'm too slow uh look look on my screen okay so like this just do this and then oh wait no guys even a pro messes up i don't play on modern that's the thing i mean i'm getting used to that you don't play on modern when it's the easiest it's the easiest mode no no no it's not about easy it's about a different layout yeah sure yo you don't have to expose you like that excuses oh pro player can't play on modern
don't make me practice modern for a day
okay okay uh okay what else uh so if someone jumps over you wait but you didn't do the thing you were trying to teach me the thing but you couldn't do it i showed you oh wait i showed you this it is okay oh okay like make them block a few more and then you can just do headbutts afterwards okay headbutts oh like that something like that yeah oh my god okay i have to hold it So this is like this is like basically that you see this button that you're pressing.
Yeah This is basically what you do in real life anyway, which is bullying.
Yeah So you're gonna want to bully so you're gonna want to bully them in the corner.
Oh my god, I'm doing it
This is one of your best buttons.
Okay.
Yeah, so if someone jumps over you yeah Someone tries to jump at you.
Do you know what to do?
What is that?
If someone jumps and you want to stop them from jumping, do you know what to do?
Oh, headbutt.
Yes, you have headbutt and you also have your this button.
Look at my screen.
Why the fuck?
Oh, it's my...
Oh.
This one also stops them from jumping.
Okay.
So this is anti-air.
Yes.
This one and your headbutt.
obviously headbutt is better but sometimes you know you're not walking back enough so you're not charging for the headbutt so this is good this is also spammable button as well you can just oh my god that's my favorite for far range for far range look how far it reaches oh oh it's pretty far yes but but the problem is it doesn't push you forward like his other button that i told you about that you can spam the the x button yeah yeah yeah this one move more moves them forward so it's good to walk into the distance the other one is just in place oh yeah get it i'm trying to see what other buttons he has oh yeah you also have the down the down heavy punch How did you do that?
Oh, this.
Yeah, it's just down this.
When do I use this?
This one's also good.
This one, it's basically the same, has the same concept as the X button because it moves them forward.
So if you're far in range, you can just, you can do this.
Look how far it reaches.
Look at the range of it.
Oh my God, it's so far.
And on, on counter hits.
It can combo into this.
This is my new alley kick, guys.
Break their ankles.
Yes, this is a low as well, yes, which is good.
I think it's a low, if I'm not mistaken.
I hope so.
I'm fucking beating up his shoe.
I hope it's a low.
This is also good if they like to walk back a lot.
So you have this button and then you have the medium punch, which you use for bullying.
And then you have the headbutts.
Why am I watching for the YouTube?
Okay.
Yes.
So these four buttons are the ones you're going to use to bully someone in the corner or just in the mid-screen.
In the corner.
Okay.
Or even outside of the corner.
All right.
I got it.
I understand.
Now what we need to do is I want to see you actually apply these moves.
Okay, I don't understand.
In a match.
What do you know what you don't understand about it?
Maybe I don't understand.
No, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
At least if I see you in a match, I can tell what you need to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going with a strategy that's like uh very simple to use not very complicated yeah and a lot of spam basically which is your favorite thing to do yeah that's my favorite as long as i can spam one to two moves that's all i need oh my god she's gold she's so good i hope one day i can be just don't know you're better don't worry i hope okay oh no you need to chill on the ex one use this use the Yes,
this one.
Oh, my God.
She's fucking me up.
Okay, but what if there's no way she'll, there's no way she'll know.
Oh.
Oh, that was nice.
That was nice attempt.
Get out of here.
Oh, my God.
She's just beating me up.
Wait, how does this player go?
Oh, yeah.
How does this player go?
She's so good!
She's gold!
I told you, she's so good!
Bro, what the fuck?
Stop!
What the f- Get me off of me!
Get off of me!
Okay, I'm okay now, I'm okay.
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, that's nice.
Easy.
I can do that.
Oh my god.
Use your stamina punch.
Yes.
Bully her with it.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh I fucked up.
It's okay.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Please get out of me.
Get off of me.
Oh shit!
Oh no.
Okay.
You know, it was a good attempt.
You were fucked up, but you fucked up.
No, I don't want to.
She's not gold.
She's not, no, no.
All right, all right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you have a get off me move that you can use if someone is pressuring you too much, which is your level one super.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this one.
Yeah, the L.
This one is a get off me move.
So if someone is pressuring you too much and you on wake up, then you just wake up with this.
Okay.
I understand.
See if I...
Oh!
No, you need to chill on the EX1.
EX1 is punishable.
Okay, but what if I just do this?
Yes, do this.
This is not punishable.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
Come on, get over here, girl.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
what have you just killed oh yeah i'll just keep doing this oh there you go i got you now that's right now i slowly back away i'm baiting her yes back away okay you're winning you don't need to do anything you don't need to do anything there Exactly.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa.
You want to come over?
That's right.
Yeah, you do.
Oh.
Whoa.
Uh, careful.
Go back to...
Oh, never mind.
Do you miss your opportunity?
No, it's fine.
There's no way I can miss it again.
Oh.
Whoops.
Not mean to do that.
That's fine.
Don't worry.
I got the slap.
I will apply it.
JK.
Oh, okay.
That worked.
that's right i got the slap oh oh wait oh wait wait oh god oh so this is not looking so good for me oh unless you're fine you're fine yeah yeah i'm so fine i'm so healthy oh shit oh shit he's cheating she's cheating she's smurfing
Oh, come on.
Well, we could do this forever.
Yeah, we could do this forever.
You can't do it forever.
Guys, I can't do it forever.
I don't understand.
But what if I do this?
I mean, it can work.
Oh.
That's right.
Oh my god, wait!
Watch this!
Get out of here!
That's right.
Can't do this in classic.
I think you can, but that's beside the topic here.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh no, wait.
Didn't like that.
So now you don't need to do anything.
You just wait for her to do something.
Okay.
Block low as well.
Don't forget to block low.
Oh.
Oh my god, what the fuck is she doing?
to me bro no oh my god yes keep doing the semi-de-punch keep doing the semi-de-punch i'm trying okay nice you almost threw there not gonna lie i just wanted to i don't like her i don't want all right all right pause the pause the search for a bit okay okay
more exciting i did okay so so when i tell you to use this yeah i don't mean i don't mean for you to go to this as well because this your turn is still alive yeah but if you do this that's and then it's no longer your turn okay no longer your turn meaning you have to block afterwards okay so after i do this i have to block after you do the hundred hand slap yes you have to block okay but if you do the set mini punch only we're gonna call that set mini punch yeah uh you're fine you don't you can do this into jab into whatever uh now i see that you have an issue like if someone knocks you down you tend to panic and you tend to press whatever yeah uh that's me try to yeah try to block more on wake up try to block more you know like i had like a 30 percent defense less yeah just try to block a bit on wake up so uh you don't lose a lot of life if you don't want to block and wake up yeah use the ex the ex headbutt wake up with it oh wait no not that this this one or use the level one super
oh if you don't want to block and wake up yeah this okay yes but like i said the ex headbutt it's good to wake up with it but it's not good to use you know randomly out of nowhere because
Yeah, so be careful when you use it.
Got it.
That's right.
But what if I just...
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
I was like, why am I not getting a game yet?
No, I told you to pause it.
But...
Okay, so how do you do this?
On wake up, yes.
Yeah, yeah.
Because if you feel like the pressure is too much.
Because they'll think I block, but then I'll surprise them.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
be like there's no way she won't block and then i'll just do this yes that or the level one so okay got it oh no ken oh no fuck your flow charts oh my god he's cold just six game win streak oh you're it's okay they won't expect this watch this all right he has a fireball this is good practice for you oh god oh god not Oh,
no.
She punished you.
Okay, it's fine.
Yes.
Oh, shit.
That's how you- I know you want to jump.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, oh my god.
That's not bad.
You switched corners.
That's good.
That's my corner.
This is my corner.
What the f- Oh, no.
Jumped over you.
That's right.
Get off me!
That worked out.
And then- Oh my god, that's not what I wanted.
Oh my god, what?
Oh my god, he grabbed me!
Oh my god, he grabbed me again!
It's okay, I grabbed him!
I grabbed him!
Oh!
Oh no!
Okay, I...
Look, he has like six wins.
I have one.
You might have to pull out your secret weapon, your butt slam.
Oh, true!
Okay, wait me.
Okay, it missed.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
As long as you didn't punish it, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, what?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
You're not expecting this, are you?
That's right.
You're doing good.
Because I don't expect it either.
Chill with the EX.
Watch this.
Oh, shit.
Don't watch it.
I'm watching.
I'm still watching.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He jumped over.
I wasn't expecting that.
Um, this is not...
No, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Um, um...
I don't feel fat...
Oh.
No!
That was close.
How come I wasn't fine?
I guess.
You were fine for a bit until you weren't anymore.
I don't want him to fire me.
I don't want him to fire.
Okay, so I...
I noticed you have an issue with jumping.
Yeah.
You're not anti-airing properly.
So if your headbutt is not working, then use this button.
This button is easier.
This one is much easier than using headbutt.
Push this one.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay.
It will stop him completely from jumping.
No, this one you need to use headbutt.
Okay.
That's always him again.
Lasagna.
I remember you.
Oh, that's him.
all right she won't expect this how come she expected it well she didn't because she didn't punish you that's right my coach taught me that that's right all right i didn't teach you that okay that's our favorite time in this
Oh, oh my god, that's fucked.
Okay, you deserve this ring.
Okay, nice.
What?
Okay, he's smurfing, he's smurfing.
Okay, okay, how are you here?
How are you?
How are you in?
How are you here?
All right, so what he's doing right now is basically just waiting for you to press something and then he just reacts.
So what you're gonna do now is you're not gonna press anything.
Yeah, that's right.
I'll wait.
And use buttons only.
Don't use specials.
That's right.
My turn.
My turn to react.
Yes, when you see him too comfortable and walking, just do your headbutts.
Oops.
Bro, your range is so high!
Why do you have such long arms?
You have longer arms, you know, you just need to use them.
Nice.
See?
My arms are so short.
He's getting frustrated.
Now he's going to want to go in.
Yeah, that's right.
I can.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh.
I didn't dodge it.
Okay, you're fine.
You're fine.
Oh, my God.
I don't feel...
Careful from the drive impact.
Oh.
No!
It's fine!
It's not fine!
Okay, I'll do one more again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
It'll be fine.
Oh.
I can- I am patient.
Oh, what the fuck?
Can you see your charging?
Just wait.
Just okay.
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna be burnt out.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, you're burned out.
Never, oh, never mind.
Oh, you're fine.
You're fine now.
Okay, I'm fine.
Yes.
Oh, I couldn't get the head.
Nice.
I got it.
Don't forget the butt and the head's the shoes.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, change your shoes first.
Yeah, she got me first.
Wait, she got me first.
I think she's listening to me.
Yeah.
Wait, that's illegal.
She's streaming.
This is my coaching session.
She's listening to me before you.
Bro.
Get out of here.
Get out.
That's the key.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Now you have a big life lead.
You should not lose this.
Oh, no.
Every time you say that, I lose this.
Okay, okay, no.
Do I have to say the opposite?
Do I have to say, okay, okay, you're gonna lose this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just be like, lose it, lose it.
And then I'll be like, I'll show you.
I'll show everyone.
Oh my god, oh my god, look what you did.
Look what you did.
Alright, now...
Okay.
Careful from the drive impact.
He's gonna drive impact.
See what I told you.
He's so smart.
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Oh, do I... No!
What?
Are you blind?
What's wrong with you?
All right.
So I noticed that in this match that you played, yeah, he's like, you're not reacting to drive impact.
Yeah.
So when someone does drive impact, you can obviously drive impact back.
Yeah, I can drive impact back.
And if you're burnt out, obviously you can't drive impact anymore.
You have to use your level one super.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's your only way of escaping driving tracks.
Now what I need you to do is sometimes when you're getting pressured too much, do not use specials.
Okay.
Try to use, try to use your jab, your button, this one.
This one.
And you can go into headbutts as well.
I got this.
Like this.
Try to use your jabs more.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Even after, even after headbutts.
It's hard to use jab.
That's right.
Like this.
I'm jabbing.
My coach is teaching me how to jab.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no.
No, I couldn't react.
Okay.
That wasn't a combo.
That's right.
Wait, this guy combo.
That's illegal.
What the fuck?
We're silver.
What's wrong with you?
Oh, I told you they're listening to me.
What the fuck?
This is my coaching session.
okay bro what this is my okay i'm sad i'm gonna die to poison now oh it's actually perfect practice for you you have an aki what did you mean to do there what did you mean to do i just wanted to grab her oh oh please don't look I don't know.
That's fine.
Stop looking.
Okay.
No, I pressed it too.
No, you can't.
You can't.
Oh, I can't?
Okay.
Yeah.
It was a punish.
Bro, what the fuck?
I swear to God, offline gaming was so easy.
Okay.
That's it.
I'm gonna use this as my helmet.
What?
Oh.
Oh my god, stop!
Stop!
You can just press your jab button there.
I feel when you block it.
Okay.
Because it's not their turn anymore, it's your turn after that.
Yeah?
Okay.
No!
What the?
Yeah.
Oh no, I didn't expect that.
What?
I didn't!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I hate you, but it's fine.
You're fine.
I'm so... I'm not.
I'm not fine.
I'm not.
Just don't panic.
I'm panicking.
Oh!
Too far.
Oh my god.
I'm not charging it.
I don't know why.
Here we go.
Okay, finally.
Oh my god.
Oh, you burnt out now.
not yet you have you have your level 2 super try to counter his fireball with the level 2 okay oh here we go do you die i mean i mean i meant to do i meant something else but this works too that works it works
she won't expect this yeah oh my gosh she expected it okay i might get burnt out all right now you need to not panic i'm panicking yes just walk back walk back that's fine okay this also works oh no she does her stupid grab get off get off me witch oh
i need to do the anti-air thing headbutt no i tried just do headbutt okay when she jumps for you that far just do headbutt yeah what the freak
god damn freak okay nice careful burned up careful don't get okay i'm gonna get burnt out i'm panicking again get oh my god you're so you're so oh she got lucky there there you go nice I hate her.
Get out.
Yes.
Oh my god.
I'm burning out.
Now you have an opportunity to do your super.
Oh, that was it.
Get out!
That was it.
Wait, do I kill her?
I don't know.
Yes, you kill her.
You kill her.
That's right.
All right.
I'm gonna need you to not at an anti-air because she's jumping a lot.
She's getting a lot of mileage from jumping Okay, okay.
Okay.
I got this.
She can't jump now She jumps.
Oh, what?
She's still jumping Okay, there you go.
I'm gonna jump again do it.
Oh my god.
My my hands were on the wrong button All right, fine.
You're out of the corner.
That's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Oh, shit No, you can you can you can drive in fact there as well.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, hmm.
But slam, maybe.
Hmm.
Do I have to pull out the secret move?
But slam?
Give me a sec.
Oh, no.
No.
That's right.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Okay.
Watch this.
Oh, not that.
I was trying to do the butt slam, but it didn't work.
Stop!
Oh my god, stop!
Okay, that's good.
Okay, she knows.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god.
It might be dead.
Oh no, you're not dead.
I'm dead now.
He's gonna drive impact.
Please don't drive impact me.
What?
No, no.
Do your level 2 super.
You can do...
Okay, that's too late.
Oh, it's too late.
It's too late.
Oh, my God.
And it's poison.
Okay.
It's winnable.
Is it?
Okay, never mind.
You gave me super confidence.
So, I mean, that's what I have to do.
I have to give you confidence.
You know what you're doing with your EX when you're burning out too fast it's like the equivalent of when you play marvel rivals and you burn all your cooldowns in one second yeah and then you defend those that's basically what you're doing but like what if i win though what the fuck give me my entire air get out oh yes okay there you go nice i don't understand it's like Offstream,
I was fighting the most stupid people and then like everyone is like fucking The next prodigies of street fighting.
Oh, I burned out.
Oh my god, and he fucking okay.
That's cool.
That's cool
You're panicking too much.
Okay All right.
All right.
No more panic.
I'm panicking
Jesus Christ, all he does is jump.
All he does is this is what...
What is he doing?
Oh my god!
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
You can't jump forever.
Right.
That's right.
Yes, exactly.
You can't jump forever.
That's right.
But you can jump as well.
You want to jump?
I know you do.
Oh my... what?
Oh.
Oh, no!
Make sure I have it back!
Oh, he's gonna punish them for that.
He's gonna punish them for that.
Nice!
Get out of here!
Now if he jumps, I need you to do the super.
I can't...
Oh, I can't!
Alright!
Oh, he could have blacked out.
Okay, okay, wait.
I figured it out.
Oh, my God.
He figured it out, too.
Ooh.
Jesus, crap.
Here you go.
Okay.
They're going to jump again.
Yes.
Come on.
You know you want it.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
Oh, what the?
That's right.
You can punish that.
When he does the two kicks, you can punish him.
Two kicks?
Okay.
Oh.
Yes.
That's right.
Oh, that's not.
Okay.
Now he went out to it.
Now it's even.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
you got both oh nice there you go oh i'm gonna choke i'm gonna choke okay never mind yes i'm okay i'm figuring it out not like that not not now though oh oh oh it's fine we both up you know it's fine it's okay
what oh no i can't do that um hi okay now you're punishing okay okay that's good you gotta jump you gotta oh my god that's vm he's gonna jump he's gonna jump okay there you go okay that worked out Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
There we go.
Don'tset.
No NO!
That's okay.
It's okay.
We're gonna jump.
I got this though!
Get out of here!
Alright what's he gonna do now?
Jump.
That's right.
Yeah?
That's right!
You wanna do that again?
Oh, oh, okay.
That's cool.
Okay, okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
Don't panic about panic, you're winning.
Am I still?
Yeah that's right I am.
That's right, I am.
Yeah that's right.
Oh, wait, that's fine.
Oh, we both...
Okay.
Why is for him to jump?
But he gotta jump.
He's gonna jump eventually.
jump yeah you got you want to jump i know you want to jump oh that's right that's right you want to do that again oh shit okay very careful one year okay there we go we figured it out we figured him out we figured it out all right i'm gonna need you to win this game now oh okay um it's one one Oh.
You remember the jinx?
Oh, you remember the...
Look what you did.
If I lose, it's your fault.
There you go.
I'm trying to prep you for the actual tournament.
I just know these.
No, this is working, actually.
This is crazy.
How long it's working, don't change it.
Exactly.
Look at that.
Oh, whoa.
I did not think he was gonna do that.
Oh!
No, it's not working.
I need you to not panic on wake up.
Yes.
It's fine.
Block.
Um.
He's, he's doing stuff to me.
He's doing stuff and it's all working.
Punish that.
No!
No, you could have punished that.
I don't!
Just press your medium punch.
To punish that, just press your medium punch.
Okay.
Like it does the suitcase.
What?
Okay.
Oh my god.
You're so...
No.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
This is still winnable.
Oh.
No!
He jumped!
He's burned out.
Okay, you can use your level two super.
Oh, no.
No, I didn't.
You can use your level two super.
No, I didn't have health enough for the armor.
No, I didn't have enough health.
I will say, you did say I will win this and then that usually means I wouldn't win.
No, no.
I said it's winnable.
I did not say you will win this.
There's a difference.
all right i'm gonna need you to use this button a bit more this button yes but it's just because they're gonna yeah the usually you go this into this which makes you lose your turn but i need to just do this okay i got this this guy he's gonna see me oh my god please we're all my sober gamers
Why?
Why did they all leave me?
Okay.
Oh, what about my grab?
Here you go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Why does he get to grab me?
That's because he pressed up to it.
Oh, it's not fair.
See?
It's too far.
If you didn't.
Oh.
Okay, yeah, my turn.
Oh, my God.
I just realized he...
Oh, no.
My turn.
What?
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
Don't block.
Ah!
You can't block there.
I know.
I tried to jump.
okay why is he just standing there i it makes me so scared yes that was good i don't like that he's just standing there oh no come on i want to i want to be able to use my slack too
yes he's burned out so good that was right got my combo get out oh he's not dead not dead he's not dead uh just just listen to me just do drive impact okay okay
no you were too late you were too late okay there you go there you go you walked too much to do it it took your time with it i thought i had time what do you mean i didn't have time You just took your time There's a difference There you go.
Oh shit.
No, no, that's fine, right?
Yes.
Oh, I did it.
That was sick.
I did it.
Did you see that?
Oh my god Now he's gonna fuck me up.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's gonna fuck me up
No, no, no.
There you go.
.
Oh, oh.
Yes, now you have meter.
No!
I couldn't react!
My turn!
Yes!
Oh, we got it!
We took those, we took those.
We took those.
We won, we won.
We won against the goal player.
We won against...
who he did oh god no he's back oh is that the same ken i don't know oh no his name is kenji no he's different this is the one is this the one he beat i don't remember one game they're all the same to me no he's not no he's definitely not oh walk back after you do the head button block walk back oh he's just grabbing me there you go nice that was good there we go haha you didn't expect that did you me too
oh that's right oh no oh no oh no oh wait who's yes me me that's right come on come on you know you want to jump come on all right all right so you need to remember you're close to burnout so Oh, that's fine.
I get to be honest.
Okay, now you can use you.
Oh, my God.
He's right.
Oh, I'm less.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Slapped you in the shoes.
He's got the foot.
Yeah, that's right.
It works, though.
There you go.
That was a good punch.
I did it.
Oh.
Oh no!
Okay, that was good from him.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
You know you want to jump.
Come on.
Get over here.
I'm scared.
Oh!
Okay, bro.
Get out.
I'm tired.
That was amazing.
that was amazing leave my lobby oh never mind never mind I guess I'll leave if you want oh my god he just grabs me I hate it
I mean to be fair it is laggy look at that mess yeah yeah yeah if you lose it's laggy don't worry yeah yeah exactly exactly I hate I hate this I hate this there you go it's because he's winning by lag we all know that oh um oh no this is bad oh this is so bad okay we fucked up it's fine yeah yeah oh no okay we we're like living by a thread right now no not all right so if he blocks a headbutt yeah try to your jab button.
My jab button, okay.
Yes, I will remember.
My jab button.
Because he shouldn't be able to walk and throw you.
He blocks headbutt.
Okay, I'm going to try it here.
Okay, never mind.
It's okay.
It's a good try.
I thought he would block it, you know?
I hear you.
Oh, wait, he didn't block it.
Oh, I tried.
No, not the EX.
Not the EX.
The EX is punishable.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
You want to jump?
I know you want to jump.
There you go.
Come on.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
The EX is punishable.
That's why you can't do a job.
The headbutt, normal headbutt you can.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
There you go.
Oh!
No!
It's fine.
It's not fine.
I don't...
I believe.
Do you?
Ah!
This is just...
Why are you just grabbing you?
He's finding you!
This is grabbing you!
I think you figured out your weakness.
he fucking they figured it out but what if i grab back that's right he doesn't expect to grab
oh oh no there you go i'm mixing it up
oh oh my god i thought the other grab other grab would have worked here i thought he would why does he stop grabbing i don't understand I keep thinking I hate him Okay Okay That was good You're still living By a threat Oh no What do I do Oh yay That kills
Okay What will he do That's right I waited this time That's right I waited again I don't see
okay am I going to overcoming it okay what am I going to do next
that's right what could I do next oh wait oh shit I couldn't press in time that was a punish that was a punish what the fuck you're classic and you did that you're in silver wait what do i do oh my god what do i do oh my god what do i do this time i'm panicking work my eye we we got a nice fight we had all right my i'm trying to do this if someone blocks your headbutt yeah use your uh your jab button uh the yeah instead of doing you because you're doing the the yes your x not your x button the square the square button yes the square okay okay after they after they block but uh it depends on the card on the player
there you go what would i do next don't forget don't forget the the shoe the shoe attack
oh that's fine what would i do next i wonder that's fucking right oh shit oh oh too early too early yeah yeah wait this guy also spams he's like me he's like if this works it works oh come on whoa whoa whoa there we go nice okay now you don't need to do anything yeah yeah that's to do bro that's right he and i were the same we both like the spam one move we're the same look he does that and i do what the fuck he's just like me he's actually i'm fighting myself right now oh my god he just he just does that what the fuck no he's getting strategy he's using my strategy he's against me i don't like it oh no no oh how is he doing that that's it that's it i'm mad now bro i'm mad what is nice okay build your meter build your meters i can have you x okay bro okay i don't know if i can you need to protect your ankles you need to protect You need to protect your item,
they're too exposed.
I can't, I'm not wearing shoes!
He's wearing shoes and I'm not!
That's fair!
Okay, I got level 3, oh my, okay.
Oh yeah, that works, that works.
I don't know why it didn't work, sort of.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's why I protected my ankles this time!
Can't spam that move anymore!
Oh my god, stop!
Okay, okay.
Okay, you're good, you're good, you're good, you're good.
Okay, chill.
There you go.
Chill, chill.
You're gonna get your meter back.
Wait, he's lag switching!
here you go okay what any button is gonna kill now yeah
don't want him done in go go again no i don't want it he's trying to break my ankles i don't like it let's see there's no guilt what's his name we don't have him in the tournament so it's bad Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's bad practice.
He's not there in the tournament.
I'm sure that's why you want him done, dude.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll only rematch people that I pass.
That's in my tournament.
Wait, it's lasagna again!
Bro, I...
Get out of this Elo!
Why are you still here?
Oh, my.
Oh, no, I fucked up.
And she knows that, too.
I'm feeling it.
You're late.
I'm feeling that burn.
Get out.
You're gonna get your EX.
You're gonna get your EX right.
Okay.
There you go.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Oh my gosh, she's just...
She's just walking towards me.
I don't like that.
Yeah.
She used to send me the punch to make, to stop them from walking.
Use the what punch?
That's your semi-dip punch.
The spam-able button.
Okay.
There you go.
Get off.
That's right.
Alright.
Oh.
Yes, to stop them from walking forward.
That's right!
That's like a stop sign for you.
Here you go.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
Stop!
Yes, exactly.
It's a soft side.
Stop!
Oh my god, she didn't stop.
She's breaking your ankles.
Stop!
Oh my god, she is!
Yes, break your ankles as well.
Oh!
That was sick.
That was good.
That was good reaction.
I got it.
I did it.
No jaywalking allowed.
That's right.
Stop!
There you go.
I don't like you.
Stop.
Yes, exactly.
Oh, that was amazing.
Oh, yeah.
That's not fair.
I don't...
Don't come close to me!
Stop!
That's right!
Yes!
Nice, okay, now you're comfortable, you're comfortable.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just watch your ankles.
That's right, get your ankles out of here.
Oh, oh, oh, that's right.
Watch this.
Oh, never mind, watch this, though.
Okay, wait, sorry, sorry.
Okay, watch this.
Oh, my God, shake it.
Good job.
Yay!
It's a stop sign work.
Yeah, yeah, stop.
You're violating the law.
Yeah.
He's in it.
We learned another move.
Stop.
No, it's not this one.
It's the other one.
Oh, yeah.
Stop.
We did.
We're winning.
We're feeling it out.
We're winning now.
Talk to the hand.
Yeah.
Stop.
in the name of the law stop jaywalking
we got it you move i'm gonna need you to jump so so if you when you jump look at my screen yeah yeah yeah when you jump try to use this button oh how do you do that it's your down x button down x okay yes it hits both sides so it can uh like go the other side i'm gonna do it here Watch this.
Oh, you don't need to do it right away.
Yeah!
Oh shit!
It worked!
Oh my god, wait!
What is she doing?
I'm spamming you.
What?
Stop!
Oh my god, I can't!
She won't...
Get out!
Here we go.
Yes.
Come on.
Yeah, yeah, girl.
Goodbye.
Oh, yeah, I can come over too.
Oh, are you guys inviting each other or what?
That's right.
Stop.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, what?
Oh, that's right.
Oh, my gosh, she just jumps over me.
Fucking.
No, she's spamming you.
She's spamming you.
She's spamming me.
Oh, like that.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know what we were both thinking of.
Like,
I don't like this.
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
Don't let her take your space for free.
She's getting space for free.
No.
That was a good try.
Good try.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll fight her again.
We had a moment when we looked each other in the eye.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh, he's mad now.
All right.
Here we go.
you know you know you want to jump again oh what are you gonna do jump again oh you want to do that again yeah yeah now you know that's right oh no oh no she's punishing me oh unless
What the fuck?
There we go.
Got that sweep kick.
You broke your ankle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
You want to do that again?
Oh, you don't want to.
That's fine.
No, okay.
I'll take this.
Sorry, you want to do that again?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
No, you got to accept it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she learned.
Oh, oh, what?
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
She's doing so...
What the fuck?
Okay, this is over.
No, no, it's not over.
It's not over.
It's not over?
This is not over.
You guys don't need to.
All right.
Oh, what the fuck?
Did you just talk?
I forgot to unfound my talk button.
I was trying to do something else.
It's okay.
I got this.
Now I have this.
I may have my top button might be next to my super button.
Yeah, you need to.
I need to.
Yeah, yeah.
I might be like buying that.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
Oh.
oh oh my god oh my god oh my god no oh my um how do i okay okay okay okay okay okay okay let's get back just get back just get back get your meter get your meter back yeah he's gonna do something stupid oh he did something stupid all right uh i need you to pause the matchmaking for bit okay i'm gonna show you something okay okay okay so so you know you know when you get knocked down yeah there's two types of wake up all right yeah so what you're doing is you're waking up in your place yeah right here look at my screen yeah yeah i'm waking up in my place that's what you're doing constantly but there's also another wake up
what's your phone wait how do you do that how do you do it modern yeah how do you do that I think uh wait oh yeah I shouldn't buy while you do that I am buying my taunt but oh yes sir so basically press your what do I press triangle I'm pressing all my buttons.
Not my button, all my punch buttons.
Uh-huh.
And I'm...
Yes, I'm going back.
So when you get knocked down, press all your punch buttons.
And you go back.
But if you don't press anything, you wake up in your place.
Try it now.
Wait, wait.
How do I unbind this?
Guys, what do I press to unbind this?
Just press the button, hold the button that does the taunt.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Nice.
all right we did it i won't throw okay so wait uh
yes so i'm pressing two of my punch buttons oh when i'm when i'm knocked down so i can go back so i can wake up so like any two yes any two okay let uh put uh put jamie to just you know sweep you or just lock it down uh go to dummy settings oh uh no no recording recording oh yes record uh make him do down no uh there's another button try all buttons try all buttons
what's your uh wait what's your red button the red button what is it yeah down down red button oh oh no okay there's another there's another button there's another you're heavy punch you what do you do to press to anti-air with I think we gotta delete that.
Let me go, Jamie.
Let me try Jamie.
How do I delete this recording?
Oh, backspace.
Okay.
Oh, it's Jamie's on classic.
Wait, it's because Jamie's on classic.
Wait, how do I change Jamie?
Wait, how do I make Jamie not classic?
All right, you need to change Jamie.
You need to change Jamie.
Change Jamie.
How do I change him?
Pick Ryu, pick Ryu.
How do I change Jamie?
Why do we collect here?
Oh, it's character select.
No, you can do it from the, what's it called?
Oh, wait, that's the wrong guy.
That's the wrong guy.
Where the fuck is that?
I just need you to record him knocking you down.
That's it.
Go Honda, go Honda Honda.
Yeah, okay.
Go Honda, Honda.
He has to be Honda too?
No, just go Honda for me to make it easier.
Okay.
Because you know all his buttons.
Wait, how come Honda doesn't even have...
Honda doesn't even have modern on the dummy?
I mean, because he's the dummy.
Oh, I say classic players.
Okay, no, press start.
Press start.
Oh, start.
Yeah, yeah, go start.
No, no, go to the environment settings.
Environment settings?
Oh, yeah.
Yes, go down, down, down.
Oh, there it is.
Yes.
Press down, change them to modern.
Okay.
All right.
No, I just need you to record them knocking you down.
Wait, what the fuck?
Press Honda.
Yes, change this.
Yes, I'll go.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
All right.
Now we can record.
Oh, not that.
oh yeah actually actually this is right this is right no no wait press start press start okay reversal settings block reversal press yes click this go crouch hanging heavy kick down first last one okay on now I need to go to dummy settings okay put it on all block Okay,
all blocked.
Yes, now go back.
Okay, so when you press a button now.
Press a button.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, she's going to knock you down.
She's going to knock you down.
Now, when you get knocked down, I need to press yes, see.
Whoops.
I don't know.
You have to get knocked down.
Yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
See, now you wake up a bit further behind.
So when Tommy was spamming you with grabs, there was a way to get out of that by doing this.
Okay.
Instead of waking up in your place so you wake up in your place.
Not  you don't have to do it all the time.
Yeah, yeah.
Sometimes you wake up  your background.
It's called background and it's called quick rise.
Quick rise is where you wake up and your place.
Uh-huh.
And backroll is obviously your back rolling.
Okay.
So you backroll to gain some space from your opponent.
Uh-huh.
Yes, so you just need to know how to do it properly.
Yeah, yeah.
Like can you do it intentionally?
is that okay yeah yeah so this is good to gain some space so you don't always stay in front of your opponent okay i i get it yeah you learn something now yeah yeah yeah now i need you to apply it in a match okay when you get knocked down by someone like if someone throws you i need you to backroll so you don't stay in his face uh-huh keep dying basically i got this I got it.
All right.
I figured it out.
Another new thing.
Now you can start.
All right.
I'm ready.
And then one day I'll be able to do this.
Oh yeah.
Wait, pause the matchmaking a bit.
Pause the matchmaking.
I need to.
I'm going to need you to look at my screen for a bit.
All right.
So sometimes I see you, this is going to be a bit difficult to learn, but.
Uh, this is going to be useful.
So I see you walking back to do the headbutts.
But when you walk back a lot, you lose a lot of space.
And then you lose, you lose the range on the headbutt because it doesn't go full screen.
Uh-huh.
Unless you do the heavy budget.
Don't want to go full screen.
But you can actually hold down back to charge.
And then as soon as you want to do the headbutt, you just, you just go, Oh!
You just stand and do it.
Oh, I can...
Oh, okay, so I can just stay still.
No, yes.
As soon as you want to do the head, you just stand.
Yeah, you just let go down and do it.
That way you don't lose a lot of space because you're walking by yourself back and you end up in the corner and then you panic and then you die and then you get sad.
Okay.
We both get sad.
Basically.
Yeah, so I'm going to need you to apply that in a match.
All right.
God, okay.
here and this oh my gosh it's a jamie not a jamie is there a character you want to fight i feel like every character you were like no not this guy he's not oh wait you expect what the fuck watch oh my god what okay that was good what is he what he guys not expecting that
waiting for you oh yeah what is wrong what is wrong with you what what me yeah me oh okay that's five that's fine we burned out too yeah what what bro is he actually drunk like i mean he's drunk now yeah i'm like is he is the guy today i'm also drunk like but What is going on?
No!
There you go.
Nice.
Yeah, that's right!
Me!
Give me your elo!
Ha!
You don't expect that!
That's right!
Oh, you don't expect that!
The leg!
Don't forget the stop sign.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Oh, my God.
I'm forgetting the stop sign.
Nice.
I don't stop that.
That's right.
That was a good combo.
Yeah, it's one button.
It's my auto button.
That's fine.
We count that.
Oh.
I don't like that.
Oh That's right leg Oh shit Oh shit Oh Am I dead Oh no no Oh no He's hot classic You block your neck My neck My poor neck What is wrong with this guy?
Okay, I didn't expect that, but I'll take those.
There we go.
We don't question things.
If they work, we don't question them.
That's right!
Get out of here!
Uh-oh.
Watch this.
Oh, don't watch this.
Oh, watching!
Are you watching?
I'm watching.
I'm not watching anymore.
Oh, shit, stop watching!
Stop watching!
Okay.
Nice.
You can...
No!
Okay, that's good.
All right.
This is one thing I need you to know also.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pause matchmaking, pause matchmaking.
Okay.
No!
No, we got it.
Okay, I have to after this.
After this.
Okay.
There's something you need to know about burnout.
Burnout is when someone is burnt out, that's when you need to go ham on someone.
Okay.
And I'll show you how exactly.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my God, I pressed the wrong button.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Yeah.
You're fine.
You see that?
I stood still.
Oh, you see that?
He thinks I used a different move.
He thinks I'm going, oh, no.
It's a different fight.
Stop.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
He's stopping me.
There was a bomb in you.
Yeah, he's stopping me.
He has better ping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Oh.
No!
No, I couldn't get out!
That's when you need to use your level one super.
Okay.
That's the only way out.
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
Come on, John.
Let me have this.
Uh, he's, yes.
I was gonna tell you, he's gonna spamming drive impact.
So I'm gonna need you to wait for it and react.
Oh.
See, I told you.
No.
Oh, no, he locked it too.
Oh, there's a punish.
There you go.
He's gonna do drive impact.
I'm gonna need you to level one super it.
Okay.
Come on.
There you go.
Yes!
Let's go!
I did it!
I finally did it after you told me to do it 20 times!
Now you have EX.
You're not defenseless anymore.
Here you go.
I'm not gonna have it soon.
he's gonna do giant impact again oh unless i block him there you go there you go there you go i did it i'm doing it oh my oh never mind okay never mind oh shit he went for it oh Shit.
Bro, you're silver.
How do you know this on Classic?
Stop!
No, I pressed it!
I swear to God!
He's gonna do it again.
Unless not.
He's gonna do it.
No.
Okay.
Nice!
Do not do the combo.
I messed it up.
Wait, no, no, he jumped.
He jumped over it.
Fucking, oh.
Stop.
Okay, I got it.
No, you can't.
You don't have enough health.
I almost got it.
Guys, I'm not on the Capcom channel today.
This is a freebie.
Tomorrow I have to make sure I don't swear.
all right uh pause matchmaking for a bit okay oh yeah forever that oh my god it's taking forever i bet like it almost found me a game all right all right so uh look at my screen yeah so wait so when someone is burned out yeah so usually when you do a headbutts Your turn is over,
right?
But if they're burned out, your turn is not over, actually.
Okay.
So you can do headbutts.
You can do headbutts and then press jab.
And then median, I mean, the stop sign.
You can just bully them with this.
But technically, this is something that a lot of high-level players want to do.
Like top player, they do this into butt slam.
oh that's a little too much yeah yeah it's a bit too much but uh i mean you get my point basically yeah when someone is burnt out yeah whatever isn't your turn becomes sort of your turn in most cases okay so this becomes much much in your turn so i have to keep doing that yeah oh this as well this one as well okay you can go this this okay all right just do that more yeah and even this Even this.
Okay.
Oh, this is zero.
Never mind.
No, it's not your turn.
It's neutral.
Oh, okay.
So just do...
Down and...
And headbutt.
Yeah, headbutt becomes really good.
But you need to press jab afterwards.
Okay.
So when you do headbutt, press your jab button.
Or this.
Okay, and then...
Okay.
But when they burned out.
When they're burned out.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If someone's burnt out, basically you gain extra frames of advantage.
So you have your more advantages when someone's burned out.
Okay.
Got it.
So you get to...
And that applies to you as well.
If you're burnt out, then that means you have to hold in more stuff.
So basically, you're expected to block more when you're burnt out.
Oh, no.
So bringing burnt out is the worst time to panic.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
I panic all the time.
That doesn't make a difference, really.
All right.
That's right.
Oh, that's right.
Not expecting that.
Are you?
Now get over here.
That's right.
That was nice.
Okay.
All right.
We need to chill for a bit.
Don't get to have a compass.
Oh, no.
I did chill.
I...
I wasn't chill, really.
I did chill.
I...
Oh no.
All right.
I'm needing to react with the level one or level two.
The diesel drive impact.
Okay.
Watch.
Oh.
Um, don't watch it.
Stop watching.
It's fine.
Oh.
no oh you should have continued pressing the stop sign but i got them oh wait wait i got it oh this is the jumpy actually oh my god it is oh my god it is stop stop that's right no oh no no she jumps
you nice oh wait what oh i forgot to it's okay nice okay yeah it's okay we're fine i'm tired but we're fine oh oh no stop there you go nice oh no she grabs me that's the character you have to fight in the tournament right yeah yeah Yeah, it's okay.
Oh, stop grabbing me.
It's not fair.
Because I want to grab you.
Oh, I'll grab you first.
Bro.
How do I get it?
Help.
Go Jelpy!
Here you go.
Okay.
No!
This is a Jelpy Aki.
Yeah.
Nice.
Stop!
Here you go.
What?
Again?
Yeah.
That's because you're walking forward.
That's why you get that.
There you go.
Nice.
Chill back a bit.
Get your meter back.
There you go.
Nice.
Get your meter back.
I'm out.
You know you want to jump over?
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
Oh.
You don't remember... Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't get my meter back.
Nice.
He's going to jump again.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
There you go.
Never mind.
You didn't jump.
Yeah, you didn't jump.
You made your mistake.
Watch this.
She never...
She lets me do it all the time.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Stop.
Nice.
Okay.
You're getting the hang of it.
Oh, no.
She's been.
She's been, she's watching the stream.
Help.
Help me.
Help me coach.
Oh, look, I'm super.
Oh, B.
I think it was over.
He's completely defenseless.
The crotch, why did you help me?
I'm trying!
I need to use also, I need to also use the back roll on Waco.
He just watched!
Sometimes you gotta learn the hard way, you know.
What did I learn?
I didn't learn anything!
Bro, you didn't teach me anything!
Bro,
is this the same guy?
Is this the guy that...
Bro, okay, get out!
Okay.
He's gonna jump, he's gonna jump.
Nice.
Get out of here.
There we go.
Oh, no, it's too soon.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God, he's fucking...
Oh, no, that's right.
All right.
You just need to press literally one...
Okay, yeah.
All right, here we go.
Is this the shoe guy?
It's the shoe guy, isn't it?
It is, yeah.
Oh, my God, it's him.
He and I...
No, I think that guy, no, I think that guy was named John.
Oh, yeah, his name was John.
Yeah.
Are they all like this?
Like, is this...
Is this...
Is this all...
How they play all the time?
Basically.
Oh my god!
Get alive!
That's right, I'll kill your shoe!
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, he's just jumping over you.
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
Okay.
Use your other anti-air as well.
Haven't it?
Oh yeah.
um it's not early too early um too early too late not too late you're passing it too early or too late when is it the right time nice i don't like this guy okay nice oh my god the press is after it.
Oh, but God, he just grabs me.
Oh, my God.
Coach.
I need to stop panicking for a bit.
Okay.
What do I do?
Now wait for him to jump.
He's going to jump.
What you didn't tell me what to do afterwards.
When he jumps, you aren't tired.
What do you mean?
I didn't tell you.
I told you a million times.
Yes, but you had to keep telling me that I'll never learn.
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I... Oh, my...
No, he didn't block a second hit!
No!
It's okay, it's very winnable.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just need to hold your place and just anti-air.
Okay.
There we go.
Yes.
Wait, he doesn't jumping anywhere.
You realize?
I need to protect your ankle as well.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Okay, that's good.
I need to press jab after after you block the headbutt.
After you block the headbutt, I need to press.
Okay.
There you go.
Stop!
Oh my god.
Stop.
He's just taking advantage of you panicking.
I wasn't.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
We stopped him.
We stopped him at least.
Why the...
Why are you looking good at you like that?
I don't know!
I'm joking!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Stop.
Try that again.
Headbutts.
Oh.
Okay.
This works too.
There you go.
Nice.
Yes.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh.
No!
It's okay.
Say it.
You're fine.
No!
What?
I'm not fine.
Stop saying that.
Stop.
Okay, okay.
Let's retrace it how you lost.
He jumped three times and you failed to enter.
What do you mean?
I did this.
I didn't.
You were doing it too late.
In that scenario, in that scenario, if someone is not close to you and he jumps, you just do headbutts.
If someone is close to you and he tries to jump to the other side, that's when you use your other anti-air.
Okay.
what oh my what happens to all my silver my turn my turn no that's right punish that's like a punish wait wait yes go crazy on me punish I did it I punished it
that's right i'm downloading coach are you watching this oh not this not this not this not i'm still watching no no stop stop stop stop stop stop stop no it's okay grab them oh too late how can i be faster how can i be faster Okay, just block, block, block.
I am!
I don't know if you're done!
I am blocking if you want the shift!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I need you to know I was blocking.
You're blocking there.
You're blocking glow while he's jumping.
You need to block up.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, that was my bad.
Oh my god.
Are you playing in modern as well?
combo oh it's because i told you the watch
oh no i fucked up oh no it's okay it's okay it's okay we're gonna jump we're gonna jump we're gonna keep jumping it's okay i'm living by a threat no you're not no you're not You don't have enough health to block.
It's okay.
There you go.
Oh!
I thought faster!
Okay, I gotta make sure I don't...
Don't use any special.
Oh!
It's fine though.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Oh!
Oh, I was trying to grab.
Yeah, no, I was trying to do a butt stab, but it didn't work.
All right, I need to block.
Back roll.
Don't forget the back roll.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
You're panicking on these are too much.
You need to learn.
You need to block.
You need to remember to watch.
I shall block.
Oh, shit.
It's not your time afterwards.
Nice.
No!
What?
Not the auto combo!
That was auto combo diff.
Don't worry, I can do that too.
Like, soon, soon.
Like, not here?
Okay, remember not to panic.
There you go.
No!
I pressed our one!
I pressed it!
oh no i see no no you're fine it's fine okay okay so when someone jumps over you need to block the other side so because what he was doing is he was he was doing cross-up cross-up is when they jumped the other side you need to block the other the other way that's cheating you need to block the other way it's cheating oh my god i up wait he's also doing it okay no Oh,
that's JK.
There we go.
Haha, that's rare.
Let me rank up please.
Oh no.
I'm don't think I'm...
You're far, you're far.
Don't panic.
Stop!
Oh, wait, my stop doesn't work.
Oh, your other button.
The other button.
The other button?
You have two anti-airs.
You have the head button and the other button.
Okay.
But when they jump from far, just use headbutt.
Yes.
Oh my god, I'm doing, did you see that?
Coach, did you see that?
Yes, I saw it.
I saw it.
Did you see that?
Nice.
Yeah!
So when they jump from further away, use your headbutt.
If they jump from closer, use your other entire.
Okay.
I like this guy.
That's why you're beating him up.
Damn!
Fuck him.
Oh my god, you fucking freak.
Oh,
no.
Here you go.
That's right.
Can't drink no more.
Get out of here.
Nice.
All right.
I got your yellow back.
You got your yellow, right?
I got my yellow back!
Yay!
We're doing it.
I'm learning.
So you know, you know what the jury was doing to you when he keeps jumping to the other side?
Yeah.
You have the same with Honda.
Okay.
Which is your jump down X.
Oh, this.
This one, yeah.
Okay.
Not, yes.
See, you land the other side.
i should do that too i should try i'll try that and see if that works see go to the other side all right i'm gonna try this on the chun lee that she won't expect it why am i fighting good they don't want they don't want you to win nice that's right oh shit oh shit shit anti-air yes anti-air again oh anti-air anti-air do it again oh shit oh shit okay okay okay fuck oh no i'm not focused anymore i'm not focused anymore You're fine,
you're fine, you're fine, don't worry.
Oh no, God, what do I do?
And, oh shit!
Head button.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
All right, dude, thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh shit, I fucked it.
No!
Oh no, I fucked it up!
It's because of the anti-air it like fucked with me ever since.
Okay.
What the?
Just block it and punish it.
Okay, okay.
Come on.
Nice.
So you don't really need to do anything.
Just wait for him.
Oh, oh no!
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, you just need one more.
Oh, just five.
Oh, okay.
No, no, sorry.
You beat a gold player.
Yeah, I'm gonna fight you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
I'll punish him.
There you go.
Nice.
I'm gonna do that.
Come on, you know.
Punish him again.
Yeah, that's right.
She's just like me.
Oh,
oh wait how do i what do i what do i do for this use your stop sign you block it high this one it's uh it's a high okay oh my god oh shit she adapted but i didn't she has one other move
Use your EX headbutt for that.
Use your EX headbutt.
Okay, okay.
Oh, your regular headbutt as well.
Not like that.
That's okay.
I got this though.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Nice.
Okay.
Yes, get your meter back.
Get your meter back.
So you can chill.
Nice.
Oh my god.
2.
too far oh what okay he just did it he just did it oh my god you're not dead i'm not dead but i am going to be that one you need to block high okay you can't block it low she looked like she kicked high okay but she landed again please i remember when you used to jump it was so funny can do that again come on come on just come on come on just oh okay that's fine i'll just do that there you go okay you can you can punish that with the headbutt oh my god she's punishing me though what the what what happened nice come on oh Stop!
Stop!
Oh!
There you go.
Stop!
Oh...
Okay.
Nice.
That's fine.
Okay, you can kill him.
I'll take that.
That's not dead, I think?
No, it's not dead.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, that's dead.
Okay, okay.
Good job.
All right.
You can also use your EXS, but for that move, for that annoying move.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll wait.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
Oh, my god.
That's not fine.
Um.
It's okay.
It's fine.
He wasted two meters.
Um.
Block, block.
Don't panic.
Unless...
Oh, I...
Oh,
no, she can grab?
You have not grabbed?
Okay, I'll grab you.
Okay, nice.
You can...
There we go.
Nice.
You can win this.
Oh my god.
Don't panic, don't panic, don't panic.
I'm trying not to.
Oh.
Okay, block, block, I'm punished.
What?
She fucking zooms at that?
I didn't know she's so far away from me.
I didn't know she played.
Oh, my God.
Look, I didn't realize I did block the first one.
And then I...
There's two waves.
I didn't realize she had more than one.
Nice.
Okay.
Now you can still win this.
You can still win this.
Okay.
You have super.
Oh, my God.
Get out.
We're trying to jump.
No.
No!
All right.
To be fair, to be fair, you missed your chance to win this.
Yeah.
I didn't think she...
I thought it was one.
I didn't realize she does it again.
I was like...
I was like, let me show you something.
Okay.
so when chelny was doing this yeah lightning legs yeah right this is actually very punishable whoa okay you can press you can punish it with jab okay or your auto combo jab so you have an auto combo combo with your jab as well yeah yeah so you can punch you with the auto combo jab oh combo jab okay you i see you use your auto combo uh with the medium and the heavy but i don't see you use the this one with the jab or the jab wait is that the square yes okay auto combo square okay and you have an auto combo with the obviously i've seen you do this here i've seen you do this as well medium but i don't do the light yeah the light one is good for some uh moves that are only punishable with light or with the with the light only okay because that that move that he was doing is only punishable with the light yeah i understand yeah some moves are punishable with the light only uh so it's good to use the auto combo job uh-huh but uh some other moves obviously are punishable are high punishable
with this or uh like for example if someone does show you can yeah block it or or a super yeah you can punish it with this okay i understand uh
guys i do i swear to god i understand but doesn't mean i can i i don't know if i can do it but i understand i she doesn't learn i i'll learn i see
it's okay it'll work guys i can do it oh this is john oh my god it's john oh this is the guy that keeps doing drive impacts yeah yeah yeah it's dead ass red john the drive impact man you want to do that again john yeah john you want to do that again john i'm waiting john oh shit john me up oh my god john wait what happened john oh my god all right what do i do gosh you have to you have to react to the driving pack to the level one i can't i don't have anything john okay this is really both it's fine Oh,
not this round though, not this round.
The game, the game is still gonna move.
Don't worry.
The game is still gonna move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
Here you go.
Don't forget your stop sign button.
Stop sign.
Oh, keep.
he won't let me stop sign oh my god there you go nice he's gonna drive it back to there no there you go nice there you go nice there you go nice Okay.
You panicked.
He panicked to the job impact.
No!
John!
I thought I could get away with it.
He's gonna, the only way for him to get damage from there is, was basically job impacting you.
That's how you lost both rounds.
No!
I didn't want to fight him again.
No, no.
You're good.
You can win this.
Okay.
Nice.
Good combo.
Thinks it was one button.
Yeah, it's still a good combo.
Oh.
Back.
Oh my god, I don't like it when he does that.
It's so, so stupid.
He's gonna drive him back.
He's gonna drive him back now.
Oh, oh, I wanted, I was trying to drive him back too.
what oh oh get out okay I don't know I don't kill him but so I'm scared now no even if he's driving back to head but he's gonna die okay okay he jumped oh thank God he's still jumping oh drive yeah watch out for the driving back and watch out for jump okay nice nice the driving pack is coming any second now okay okay i'm so scared no no you're doing good you're doing good oh he's mine oh you need to chill the driving pack let him drive your intrusive thoughts kick in but it's like it's like what if what if you know he doesn't expect it this time you know i like this basically oh the guy yes he's easy to expect it all right he's expecting it all the time just for this time okay
stop There we go.
I thought he was gonna...
What do I do?
Block it.
Or that?
No, it's still.
Oh, I just got it.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Thank God!
Nice.
That's not gonna kill.
I don't think it kills.
That was a lot of HP.
okay now you can you can have but all you want you can drive him back oh my god i got my elo back and i leave i have my elo back there you go oh shit anaki i swear to god this is the same aki i swear to god it's the same aki it's her Okay, if you're stream sniping,
let me drink my water.
Aki, please, let me hydrate.
Please.
Okay.
Come on.
We know you're...
Oh my god, I hate her.
Is he teabagging?
Yeah.
Yes.
Get out.
Nice.
I know you're purposely losing, so you'll stay in the...
my elo.
Oh my god, he's fucking with me.
He's fucking with me.
What do I do?
Chill, chill, chill.
Yes, you can also jump.
There!
That works.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay, don't burn yourself.
I did it.
What did you say?
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
You have your meter back?
Oh, that was a good try.
That was a good try.
I didn't get my meter back.
You did technically.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, me first!
That's right!
Now you're getting burned out.
Unless...
Go back, back off, back off, jump back, jump back.
I'm trying!
She won't let me!
That's right!
Keep jumping, girl!
Oh.
Stop!
Oh!
Yes!
Stop!
Oh shit!
She learned.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what is she doing to me?
Nice!
Okay.
That's right, I'm sending a message.
That was good, that was good.
That was good.
That's right, stop.
oh no oh wait i didn't mean to do that that was an accident but what if i do that
okay that's right get out of here
oh wait i didn't mean to oh oh i pressed the wrong button that's fine that's fine that's fine that's fine i don't feel fine i don't feel fine i don't feel fine i don't feel fine you're fine you're fine Just don't panic.
No!
I didn't panic.
I didn't panic though.
You didn't panic.
Don't I please.
Oh my god.
I can't.
She's like...
She's just...
I...
Oh my...
Stop!
I...
Jump over.
My hands were on the wrong button.
I mispositioned my buttons.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, I couldn't anti-air this.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Oh!
Here we go.
Oh, punished.
I don't like it.
Oh my god.
Stop.
No, don't do anything for the fireball.
Just block it, it's fine.
Just block it.
Yeah, we'll jump over it.
Jump over it.
Okay, I block.
Alright.
Or jump over it, yeah.
I block.
I'm an easy to jump out of.
Yes, like that.
all right oh there you go yeah i keep doing that you need to you need to finish the combo yeah that's right oh i don't i don't remember the combo i do the medium auto combo okay okay nice
don't use the extend there you go that's fine that's fine
There we go.
Ah!
Okay.
Oh no, oh no, she knows.
No!
Stop!
Oh, I could have used level 2 super there.
Okay, so...
So when you jump over someone and you get a king jump in, yeah.
You can just do this.
Well, uh...
what basically oh yeah because you're getting a lot of jumpers yeah they're not punishing it or you can just do this or easier what what did you do so you were doing this you were doing the heavy punch yeah yeah yeah but you didn't you were not converting into damage so you're just doing this and then walking back so do this and then what what what's after that what did you do It's the medium.
Yeah.
Or the light auto combo.
Go for it.
Oh.
Nice.
There you go.
Oh shit.
That was too early.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jump, jump over them.
Okay.
Don't block them.
Yes.
What the fuck?
That was the slowest punch I've ever seen.
That's an overhead.
Yeah, spam.
Oh, unlucky.
Unlucky.
Oh my god, he spammed me!
That's fine, that's fine.
I'm not fine.
Don't forget your spam button, your medium button.
Oh my god.
There you go.
No!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I used to press the wrong button.
Oh, I'm on the wrong side now.
Jump, jump over there.
Here.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's fine, it's fine, this is fine.
This is fine, I'll take this, I'll take this, I'll take this, I take this.
Don't be afraid to jump at him, it's fine.
Okay, now I'm afraid though.
Nah, I'm afraid.
What the fuck?
Get out!
Nice.
Oh my god.
He's just going to keep...
Oh my god, do I hit this?
No!
He blocks it!
Okay.
Okay, you have EX meter back?
Nice.
No!
The game!
Ah!
Not you now!
No, you're fine, you're learning, you're still learning.
I'm learning, I'm learning, I'm learning, I'm learning.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're good, you're good, don't worry.
Oh shit, okay, I thought he was close enough.
Oh my god, oh, don't get...
That's it.
Protect your ankles.
Try my best.
Oh my gosh, oops.
Don't be afraid to jump, don't be afraid to jump.
I'm afraid.
Okay, there we go.
Don't burn yourself.
It's muscle memory.
I just wanted to give him a little freebie, you know?
Just to...
My ankles!
Your ankles are not protected.
My ankles.
But time would be good, yeah, yes.
Okay.
My ankles, my poor little ankles.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
Your ankles are protected either.
Nice.
That's right.
Okay.
What would be the best move for that?
Which one?
When I get him, when I...
Oh my god.
my oh oh no okay okay that's
right nice oh chill oh thank god okay okay okay okay we're fine we're fine we're fine that was close that was close nice
oh i didn't think he would do it again oh my god
um goodbye you love going to burn out huh i can't open
there you go nice you almost got your meter back
here we go nice okay oh okay i'll take those now you just need one headshot yeah that's a good win oh my god i adapted he was up around and he came back uh ryu you have to fight ryu in the tournament right ryu aki and the yeah yeah but he doesn't wait that's a punishment i can punish you okay use your butt slam as well if i remember Oh my god,
this is the first time.
I'm so easy.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh.
Oh my god, I tried to...
Please stop.
Okay, you got two meters back.
Okay.
Nice.
Now my emeter's gone soon.
No, it's fine.
Okay, oh.
Is he...
He's trying to do fireballs, but he's missing.
Oh, he's missing, yeah.
Oh, shit, my ankles!
Your ankles are not protected.
Oh, why can't you wear shoes?
Nice.
Oh.
I'm TP now, I'm EP, I'm EP, I'm EP, I'm EP, I'm EP, someone said help.
Jump.
Yeah.
Stop!
Oh, no.
Nice.
How come I couldn't punish that?
Oh, thank God.
Go for the level three.
This is the only way.
No, if you drive him back to him, you stun him.
Okay.
Nice.
That works too.
Yeah!
Oh, I fucked that up, but he doesn't know that.
My turn!
That's right!
Oh.
I'm EP again, I'm EP again, I'm EP, I'm EP, I'm EP.
That's fine, that's fine.
Jump, jump.
Okay.
Here we go.
Nice.
My turn.
You're fine, you're fine.
Am I, I don't feel fine.
I don't feel fine.
Oh, VP again.
A BP, a VP, a VP.
We can now E VP as well.
Oh.
No!
No, but that was a good try.
That was a good try.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, I've learned.
So if you drive impact to someone.
Yeah.
Okay.
And it hits, you know, you crumple them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't use your medium auto combo.
Use your heavy auto combo.
Okay.
For more damage.
Okay, okay, okay.
I see you go.
And what's it called?
If you, if someone, if you, if you're driving back to someone, you don't have enough meter, just use the command.
Just use the grab.
The grab.
Okay.
Or yeah, just use the grab.
God.
Oh my.
I swear to God.
Is this the same guy?
It's ass.
It's all like, oh my God.
It's new athlete.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Thank God.
than you are.
Hey,
get out!
Oh, get out!
Oh shit.
Nice, stop sign, stop sign.
Stop!
Oh!
Stop, stop!
Stop!
Nice!
There we go.
Hahaha!
Okay, we figured it out.
Oh.
Oh, break your ankles.
Okay, you're too close to me.
I don't like that.
There you go.
That's right.
Stop!
She doesn't know how to deal with the stop.
No, but she stops me.
I told you, it's a good button.
There you go.
That's right.
I'll break your ankle.
Oh, she's scared.
Yeah, I know you're scared.
What?
EX.
Easy, actually.
They jump here.
Oh, no!
Oh!
I'm scared!
I win!
Okay.
The one time.
Tiny King worked.
We did it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, good combo.
There you go.
Oh!
Now I need to chill with EX.
Okay.
Or maybe I don't!
Okay, I mean, that works too.
That works too, I guess.
I didn't have to!
Oh!
Okay, we both hit each other.
What?
I messed up.
Stop.
Don't be afraid to keep using the stop button.
Just use it for a normal.
It's fine.
Oh.
I messed up.
Because I'm on the wrong side.
I don't like being on this side.
All right.
Go back.
Get back.
Oh, thank God.
She gave me my side back.
Oh, my God.
She knows.
She knows I don't know how to do this side.
So that's your weak side, though.
Yeah, yeah.
That's my weak side.
Stop!
Yeah, keep using.
Yeah, keep using!
That's right.
Stop!
Get on this side!
Oh, wait, no!
No, no, no, no, no.
No!
No takebacks.
Give me out.
Oh no, get back on the other side, please.
Oh my God.
Please, please.
I just got back.
Okay.
Don't panic.
the side i'm on this side i'm panicking get your meter back get your meter back don't panic chill oh thank you thank you don't don't don't jump back jump back jump back yes good yay i got my email back again i'm like you're ranking and deranking at the same time we're learning we're learning we're doing it no you're doing good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna need you to try one game where you just keep pressing the medium.
The medium?
This?
Stop.
Yeah, when you get close, just keep doing this.
Okay.
Don't press anything else.
Don't cancel it.
Don't do anything.
Just keep pressing this.
Just keep pressing.
See how long it takes them to.
Block it?
To, I don't know, figure out how to get out of it.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'll use headbutton close, and then I'll keep doing this.
We can do it.
Oh, shit.
seen this guy in so long.
Did he got nerfed or some shit?
I haven't seen Luke players in so long.
Give me just two minutes.
I'll get back.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
Coach, we're...
No!
Coach!
It's not fine, Coach!
When he... When I need him he's gone okay when the world needed him he's bad to leave okay oh my god it's not working he told me to use the medium but it's not working guys I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
It's not working!
Oh, wait!
Keep doing it!
No, you stopped, he hesitated!
I did!
No!
Okay.
I...
Block, block, block,
and the drive impacted.
Oh, no, it's too late now.
So what he's doing there is you can just drive him back to it.
Oh, okay.
Or you accept buttons.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
Oh.
You're gonna do it again.
Block.
You need to block.
What?
Oh, my God, he jumps!
I...
Oh, no.
Oh, too far.
oh my god it's i'm not okay i'm not okay i'm not i'm i'm
see the the problem here was you didn't want to block so he just kept getting like free damage out of you how did he know technically he can uh what's it called you can just punish that uh you can look at him you can pause matchmaking and look at my screen yeah in case you face him again
so he does this yeah you can you can drive impact in the middle or you can block and just use your auto combo your jab auto combo oh okay the light oh no not the jab auto combo just use the jab headbutt the jab hip yeah like this oh okay punish okay or if you use just a headbutt it's i mean a drive impacted okay at worst case scenario you just uh what's it called you use the ex headbutt gotcha like this i understand okay but i don't even need to know that because i don't fight a luke so okay yeah i mean it's not in the tournament you don't have to yeah yeah i don't have to worry about it to be fair i don't i just need to remember how to block that's the most important part all right yeah because you're just getting free hits Let's get this lucky.
I just need to remember how to block.
Oh my god.
Zangief.
Oh no.
Oh my god a gold Zangief.
I'm so scared.
That's your character.
A fight with my pass.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
is what oh don't get close get out stop stop don't get don't get away yes this is good get away
oh oh oh he did that okay oh my god oh my god he's so good he just starts grabbing nice just keep just keep waiting for him he's gonna he's gonna do a jump I know you need to get close to me.
You need to get close to me.
That's right.
Nice.
That's why I hate it.
That's why I'm not playing you now.
Because I know I can't get close to you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
I got him.
Oh.
Stop.
Don't get close to me.
Oh.
All right.
Don't get close.
That's right.
No, you need to chill with your headbutts.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh my god.
After he blocks the headbutt jump.
Stop.
Oh fuck.
I didn't protect my ankles.
Yeah.
My ankles.
My poor ankles.
So after you do the headbutt and he blocks it, try jumping.
Okay.
Yeah, if he blocks.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
If he blocks.
Jump.
Yeah!
This is why I can't play you anymore!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Nice.
It went out.
Yeah!
I got level three too!
Get out of here!
Oh!
How did you do that?
How did you even miss that?
Yeah!
I'm fast!
Holy shit!
And I'm so...
Oh my god.
Okay.
You can end this.
No!
Don't!
That's the chase!
That's a lot!
I don't know.
To be fair, to be fair, to be fair, honestly speaking, being blunt, you deserve that loss.
Because you dropped that combo at the end.
That was a kill.
That was a guaranteed kill.
I don't know what I did.
I need to start, I need to stop saying this.
I don't know what to do with all that confidence.
I'm not.
Okay.
There
we go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Now you don't drop it.
They might have made a mistake there.
I couldn't help.
Oh shit.
Go back, go back, go back.
Oh, where did I go?
I should have gone back.
Yeah, get your meter back first and then you can go in.
Stop.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Like, don't you told me to do it?
I mean, it wasn't working.
Yeah, it was working.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot of damage.
Get your meter back.
Okay, okay, okay,
okay.
Okay.
What?
Oh my gosh, she poisoned.
be that's fine you're fine i'm sorry sorry i don't mean to say that you gotta lose it i know
there you go nice my god i know you want to jump oh no oh that's good i got it
that's right Stop.
Oh!
Pick up over you.
I don't like that.
Oh.
Oh my god, please.
Oh!
Get to me.
Oh my god, I'm- I'm EP.
I'm so EP.
Get to me to back.
Get to you.
Oh!
Good!
Jumped into it!
You jumped into it!
Here we go.
Stop.
Oh.
Alright, when they jump, you need to answer that.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Get your meter back.
Watch this.
Jump, jump.
Get your meter back.
That's where I got your shins.
Jump over it.
Oh!
No!
She grabbed me!
Okay.
It's fine.
All right.
It's like she knew how to fight me now.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad.
I'm- oh, this is so bad.
This is- oh, she's choking me.
what if i just slowly oh what if i just slowly okay just need 20 extra bucks nice see okay all right all right i got an idea now what's the idea nice that's the idea it's working No, shadow counts!
It worked though, it worked for a bit, it worked for a bit.
You have to admit, it did work.
I just...
Now she's making sure I don't get close to her.
Look, look, look, she's adapting!
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
Don't exit, don't exit, don't exit.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Nice.
All right.
Now he needs one.
Oh, can I remind you to kill them?
That's how you do it.
You figured out the formula.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Oh, now she's now she's changing it up.
She's not letting me get close anymore.
Unless.
Oh man, let me get close to you girl.
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Oh my god, she's changing up her...
She's mixing it up now.
It's illegal.
Oh, Toe Kit.
Fuck off.
Stop.
Oh, I don't...
When you jump, press your heavy button.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, like that.
Oh my god, I wanted...
There you go.
Nice, funny.
Oh.
Oh, chill with the ice.
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
Oh, I thought I'd get mine first.
There you go.
Nope.
Huh, that's right.
There we go.
Get over here!
So you basically stopped playing Zangief and you went to another character that basically does the same thing.
Oh, damn it!
I was gonna grab her!
Nice.
This is what I do in Zangief!
You just grabbed you?
Yeah!
Oh my god, she won't let me grab her anymore!
I don't understand!
That was fantastic!
Stress!
There you go.
Oh shit.
Not nice.
That's not, oh god, that's not nice anymore.
Believe me too, build me too.
Jump.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
That was gonna be it.
Oh my god, we're so scared.
We're both so scared.
Oh, it's too far too far.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
We're both so scared.
And...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
I tried.
That was close.
That was nice.
I was close.
I went to DP.
Can you pause a bunch of shaking for a bit yeah yeah yeah oh so there's something i don't see you do which is wouldn't let me pause oh what is it what is it it's uh perry or the fireball yeah yeah yeah and dry brush yes it's because it's so it's a lot okay oh my god what oh my goodbye no he's gonna grab you to death
unless unless he doesn't get close to you yeah nice okay I got I can't be EP I can't be EP I can't be EP
oh my god oh my god don't let him jump to you for free there you go
okay nice Oh!
Oh!
I'll grab it back!
Oh, what?
Too early.
That's unlucky.
If you walk up the XR by there, that would be good too.
I know you want to get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
There we go.
Don't be afraid to use a regular headbutt.
Here we go, come on.
Ah ha ha!
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
This is the kind of match you want to play campy a bit.
Yeah, yeah, that's right, that's right.
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Get off of me!
Oh, fuck, okay.
He was too mad, he got a bit.
Oh my god, that was half my HP.
Oh, oh, no, what the fuck is oh my god.
Oh, hey, you're fine.
Um, um, um, what did we say about saying you're fine?
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I forgot.
It's because he said I was fine.
Guys, these cells.
Every time I say, every time I said you're fine, you literally lost your life.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's when my brain was like, she's not fine.
What do you mean it's all my fault?
It's not my fault.
Yeah, no, no.
It's a, it's a pattern.
Every time you said I'm fine, it's never fine.
It's a pattern.
But yeah, I don't.
I feel like I would be, I'll have very bad timing if I do this.
I know the good thing about this is if you headbutt someone and you say you landed a hit if you drive rush you can continue the pressure oh I see so for example yeah for example if I do this see okay so okay something like a bit more advanced they can learn later okay alright if I play this game after the tournament basically
oh man we got this guys we got this I can win at least one game the only the only problem with me telling you you're fine is as soon as they say you're fine you start panicking and you get hit by literally everything that's not what you're fine supposed to mean you're fine supposed to make you calm not panic it's because I'm like am I actually fine I don't know He told me I'm fine.
I just forget everything you've taught me.
All right, I'm going to need to tell you're cooked.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm cooked, and now it would be like, I'm like, I'm not cooked.
I'll prove you wrong.
And then I unlock my third eye.
It's okay.
We got this, guys.
I believe.
I believe in Big Bird, who believes in me.
I do believe in you.
you believe in me guys but the problem is you don't believe in yourself like i do yeah because i yeah but i believe in you i don't believe in myself i believe in you
this is gonna work guys i think i might have to bounce after the next all right next game will be the lg i will prove to you big bird i will do to you everything you've taught me i'll show you everything you've taught me during the last game and i might lose but it doesn't matter if you lose or you win as long as you're learning as long as i do the moves you taught me you're fine i'll be fine where the fuck are the players i have five players cancelled on me do they know did i want and done too many people that they don't want to fight they all blocked it yeah they all blocked me they all blocked me is that why my cues are so long now guys i'm blocked me please i need to show my coach or it might be or it might be like 12 a.m right now yeah no no that can't be it that can't be are you sure this is peak gaming hours this is the hours where everyone should be gaming well to be fair you had like a rotation of five players that you were playing in a row that's true and you kept one and
gunning them so maybe they all blocked you oh no why would they block me why you ask me why i don't understand there's not a lot of us come on you gotta take what you can get i don't understand all right uh what you need to do uh cancel the matchmaking and then put it on again okay wait wait maybe okay maybe that's it oh wait it's searching i can't escape oh oh it won't let me press escape that means they found someone i think i can't leave when there's that like uh oh a communication error oh no oh my god my game doesn't even want me to fight another person like oh no oh okay there you go all right off all right turn it off and then turn it on all right and then we'll do all we'll end it on someone with one bar or some i don't care like are you sure you don't care yeah it's fine if i'm lagging they're lagging so we we can both suffer all right okay i swear to god if this is the I swear the guy.
Oh, my God.
It's a new Aki.
A Brazilian Aki.
Oh, my God.
This shit looks laggy.
Stop.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
I'm laggy.
She's laggy.
We're all laggy.
Yeah, we know who works better than lag Honda.
Exactly.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
Damn!
What?
How did she know?
Stop.
stop stop stop oh oh my god she could jump
bro this is i hate this what i hate oh my god block block block yeah oh no you're late just go for the auto combo right away okay i got it okay nice do i get it don't spin the BUT DON'T, DON'T SPIN the emitter.
WHAT?!
I didn't mean to stop playing!
I pressed out!
I pressed it!
IT DIDN'IT!
I- I S Pors Again!
I Swear It Again!
I swear it again!
No, no, no, I swear it again!
And- But it just, I- I was just as confused.
I- I- I- It's a lag!
I- I- No!
I swear it again!
It's like it's disconnected.
Yeah, no, I was pressing it.
I was like, what happened?
Wait.
There we go.
Okay, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now.
Okay, good.
Finally.
There we go.
He's going to let me down this time.
I don't know why I just stood there.
Yay, we were last kidding.
yay we did it we did it are you proud okay not that part where i stood still but like i'm proud of you you're proud of me yes i'm proud of you proud of me i did it i'm part of the bridge family that was a good last game even though it was one and done yeah yeah look i didn't I didn't want to...
Are you sure that was the reason?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thinking about you, you know, your time, you know?
Ah, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, I'm such a good student.
That's very nice of you.
I know, I know.
I'm so nice.
I know.
Let's all chat.
Let's all say thank you to the big friend for coaching me today.
I learned so much.
I learned this is my favorite move now.
Stop.
This is my favorite move.
favorite thank you you think i can you think i can win one game in the tournament will you watch you can uh you should watch what time it is it's really yeah you can lie to me too if you want no no i'm gonna i'm gonna watch it so you're playing really it's that yeah i'll watch it oh my god i don't it's i don't even know what time it is like you don't even know i need to look it up I forgot it was I don't I did I look at my schedule on the day it's at oh it's at 4 p.m.
good luck it's like that would be like how it's time it would be like 4 a.m.
yeah that would be 4 a.m.
I'll try to stay up if I say that I'll try I'll try no promises thank you no promises oh my god thank you again big bird for coaching it was very fun i'm happy to help yeah yeah you're very fun student oh yay thank you you're a great teacher you're a fun teacher too oh thank you yeah i hope you have a good stream and uh yeah good luck in the tournament i'll try to watch yeah and if you don't say i'm fine questions don't okay i want to cook don't worry yeah yeah yeah when you're in chat watching just be like doke is cooked and then and then i'll unlock my potential yeah well if there's anything you need you can just message me yeah yeah of course of course thank you again big bird it was really fun happy coach yeah you too good luck what what are you doing after this uh i'm gonna have to run some errands because uh early in the morning oh yeah well it's not early it's like 12 p.m yeah yeah yeah Yeah,
he doesn't have to do real life shit now.
He's got no more video games.
GG's, GG's.
All right, have a good one.
You too.
Bye-bye.
Goodbye, chats.
Yeah, say bye to Big Bird, guys.
Bye-bye.
All right, see you guys.
Oh, my God.
That was so fun.
I had a great time being coached by Big Bird.
Big bird.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I was so scared in the beginning.
He was such a fun teacher.
I had a lot.
I had a good time being coached by him.
And I learned my new favorite move.
Stop.
And also this.
Oh my god.
The alley kick.
And nobody blocks this.
No.
Okay.
Except for him.
He's a bot.
He's meant to block it.
But nobody.
I found out.
Nobody actually blocks this.
And stop.
Stop.
my new alley you finally the law all right but thank you all for watching everyone that was really really fun um i honestly i'm happy that i reached out to big bird for the additional coaching because he did help a lot as well um he did help yeah i need to remember this punch too wait not this one just punch yeah but it's not as cool it's not as fun as this Guys,
this brings back alley-kick memories, guys.
This brings back alley-kick memories.
It's not as good.
Not as good.
This, this, not as good as this.
But I think I improved a lot.
I think I improved a lot today, and I learned a lot of cool moves.
One last butt slap.
If I can pull it off.
Yeah!
Oh, look, I pulled it off.
But, um, I'm gonna head off now.
Tomorrow's no stream.
I might show up on Nephew's stream for the extra coaching on the Capcom channel, the Capcom Fighters channel.
And I won't be there for too long.
But thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up from me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye